let's go to the five one nine area code
caller from 500
hi that's me that's you all right um so
one of the sorry my name is Nathaniel by
the way all right go ahead and this kind
of relates to an earlier question that
was asked about um about the Russia
about Russia on the left yeah so um
you're somebody who's clearly on the
left and you're also very concerned
about no Russian interference in the
election and I I'd put myself in summer
camp as you uh what do you make of the
the the information indicating that
before the Russians back trunk they
backed Sanders I don't mean for this to
be like a gotcha saying I'm just
generally genuinely curious oh he makes
it sometimes feels like the elephant in
the room in these conversations I don't
know a thing about it what tell me more
um okay yeah there's some articles about
there's one published by Jamie Kerchak
he's a bit of a neoconservative so he
he's got a bias but um it's reasonably
well sourced I believe it was and it
might have been a tablet I'm not sure I
think it was tablet um but he there some
other information out there that but the
rest that Russia was supporting on
Sanders like or like quotes supporting
Sanders they're they're pushing a lot of
their propaganda was Pro Sanders early
on and then it kind of also then became
more proton but um yeah so here's here's
the thing the corneal I'm I'm limited in
sort of what I can say because I've not
seen it but if the idea is to create
instability which is really the broader
Russian geopolitical goal it would make
sense that during the primary you would
try to hurt Hillary Clinton by
supporting her opponents and then
because she's sort of as the
establishment candidate she is the sort
of beacon of stability and sort of non
change in the election and then once the
primary is over and Trump is the
Republican nominee and Hillary as the
Democratic
nominee the same priority of just
creating chaos and instability in the US
would have you supporting Donald Trump
against Hillary Clinton so it doesn't
sound like there's a confusing logic to
it but I don't know the specific so I
wouldn't really be able to say more all
right yeah yeah what you just said is
pretty much for flux what I think about
it it's just something that hasn't
really been talked about yeah I'm not
much in liberal circles oh yeah well are
you cut are you calling from Canada by
the way I am yeah you are I thought I
picked up on that Canadian accent which
we love by the way we love it yeah cool
all right thanks very much Mike okay
appreciate it thank you so much yeah I'm
gonna look into that I mean that yeah
that's interesting I want to find out
more about that